[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليالي الاختيار استهلها بابرز
[موسيقى]
حقبه جديده في العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه
تتوج باتفاقيات شراكه شامله وتعاون
استراتيجي
ومن رئيس الوزراء الياباني يجدد دعم بلاده
لاوكرانيا في مواجهه الغزو الروسي
اجراءات امنيه مشدده في نيويورك تحسبا
لاعمال شغب من انصار ترامب حاله اعتقاله
اليوم
مزيد من التضييق على تيك توك في اوروبا
وعشنطن تكشف عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات
المواقع الحكوميه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الروسي الفلاديمير بوتين ونظيره
الصيني
يواصلان محادثاتهما في موسكو اليوم وعيون
واشنطن تراقب وتترقب هذه الاجتماعات
بتركيز شديد التعاون الاقتصادي بين
البلدين ربما يكون منقذ اقتصاد روسيا في
ظل العقوبات وهو جعل من المبرر ان يكون
الجانب الاقتصادي في صداره مباحثات
الزعيمين
نعمل على تطوير شراكاتنا في كافه المجالات
سواء التجاريه او الثقافيه وايضا شركاتنا
على المستويين الاقليمي والدولي بالامس
وخلال عدد من اللقاءات والمباحثات قمنا
بتبادل وجهات النظر حول مسارات التعاون
وسبل تعزيزها ولقد توصلنا الى نتائج
ملموسه في علاقاتنا المشتركه وايضا حول
سبل العمل على تطويرها وتعزيزها محادثات
اليوم جماعه فودن حكوميه من الطرفين هدفها
توقيع على اتفاقيتين رئيسيتين لتوسيع
شراكه شامله وتعاون استراتيجي وفقا
للكراميل اتفاقيتان تضمنان في حياه في
طياتهما جانبا عسكريا وهو ما يخشاه الغرب
القلق من تزويد الصين لروسيا بالاسلحه في
حربها ضد اوكرانيا
زياره الرئيس السوني سمحت لبوتين باظهار
انه ليس معزولا دوليا خاصه وان الصين لم
تدن الحرب الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا وهي ملتزمه
بمفاوضات السلام زعيم بيكين كان واضحا في
تاكيدها ان بلاده طولي العلاقات مع روسيا
اولويه على اعتبار ان البلدين قوتان
كبريان جارتان استراتيجيان ومن هذا
المنطلق طرحت الصين مبادراتها للحل في
اوكرانيا وهي مبادره تحظى بتقدير زعيم
الكريم الذي قال انه يدرسها باحترام غير
ان الدول الغربيه تعتبر ان دعم بكين
لموسكو لا يسمح لها بان تكون وسيطا ذا
مصداقيه الرد على اتهام الغربي جاء على
لسان المتحدث باسم كريم
والذي قال ان الولايات المتحده والدول
الغربيه تمنع اوكرانيا من التفكير في اي
محادثات سلام بين موسكو وكياف وذلك في
الوقت الذي يستقبل به الرئيس بوتين نظيره
الصيني في الكلام الذي سيناقش خطه السلام
الصينيه المطروحه بين موسكو وكاف اما من
وجهه نظر بوتين فالعلاقات تدخل رحله جديده
بين موسكو وبكين بغض النظر عن حسابات
اوكرانيا
الدراسي العمليات الحسابيه التجاريه التي
تجري بين روسيا ودول اسيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه وافريقيا سوف تتطور ضمن العملات
الوطنيه وبالدول الاخرى ايضا يمكن ان تتم
عبر اليون وهناك ايضا تعاون في بناء
الطيران المدني وبناء السفن وصناعه
السيارات ونحن مستعدون لدعم الاعمال
الصينيه في تعويض الشركات التي انسحبت من
السوق الروسيه
وبعد الاجتماعات المكثفه قالت روسيا
والصين في البيان مشترك ان العلاقات
بينهما وصلت الى اعلى مستوى لها على
الاطلاق لكنها ليست موجهه ضد اي دوله اخرى
كما اضاف البيان الروسي الصيني لن يكن
هناك رابح ان اندلعت حرب نوويه البيان
المشترك بين موسكو وبيكين صدر بعد محادثات
استمرت يومين بين الرئيسين الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين والصيني
جين بينك في موسكو
مزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه الزياره تنضم
الينا من موسكو كاتيا طعم مراسله العربيه
كاتشا يعني
مخرجات هذه الزياره ما هي لو سمحت
مرحبا ليال بالفعل الزعيمان الروسيه
والصينيه وصفاء هذه المحادثات بانها
محادثات بناءه طبعا هناك على الصعيد
السياسي اولا توافق بالوجهات النظر بين
الجانب الروسيه والصيني على جميع المحافل
الدوليه وبالاخص كانت تحدثت منذ قليل
موسكو انها سترد في حال تم استخدام
السلاح النووي وكانت الصين ايضا في هذا
البيان نهائي دعت الى طبعا عدم استخدام
السلاح النووي وتحقيق التوازن بين الدول
الخمس في عدم استخدام هذا السلاح النووي
هذا من جانب ومن جانب اخر طبعا في على
الصعيد الاقتصادي كان هناك طبعا توقيع عشر
وثائق من بينها وثيقتين حول تعميق التعاون
الاستراتيجي الصيني من جانب والتعاون
الاقتصادي من جانب اخر الرئيس الروسي تحدث
ان هناك
تعاون اقتصادي على صعيد الطاقه سيتم
توسيعه بين البلدين ان كان سواء في اطلاق
مشروع قوه سيبيريا اثنان لزياده امدادات
الغاز الروسيه الى الصين بالاضافه لذلك
مشاريع تخص ايضا امدادات النفط بالاضافه
لذلك المحطات النوويه الكهربائيه التي
تقوم بناءها روسيا في الصين بالاضافه لذلك
كان منذ الصباح قد اجتمع الرئيس الصينيين
مع رئيس الحكومه الروسيه الذي من جانبه
اكد على ان روسيا استسعى الى زياده
التبادل التجاري مع الصين الى نحو 200
مليار دولار في هذا العام وهذا اكيد طبعا
يؤكد على اهميه هذه الزياره من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه لروسيا ستكون الصين هي الباب
او المخرج من في ظل العقوبات التي تم
فرضها عليها من قبل الدول الغربيه
وامريكا ايضا
كانت يعني بموضوع تطوير توريد الطاقه
وتصدير الطاقه من موسكو الى بيكين من
المعل وم بان بيكين اليوم يعني تعتبر
موسكو هو المورد الاساسي لها بعد العقوبات
هناك مشاريع ايضا سيتم يعني الشروع بها
بعد هذا هذه الزياره ما هي
كما تحدثت لك
بالدرجه الاولى هو مشروع خط انابيب قوه
سيبيريا 2 الذي هو سيكون بالاضافه الى
المشروع الاول الذي تم بناؤه هو الانتهاء
منه وهو قيده العمل هو مشروع لامدادات او
زياده امدادات الغاز الروسي الى الى الصين
طبعا روسيا توجهت نحو الصين ونحو اسيا كما
تعلمين
بعد فرض العقوبات عليها وبعد فرض العقوبات
بالتحديد على توريد النفط والغاز الروسيين
وتحديد السقف اسعار
لهذين الموردين من الطاقه لذلك روسيا الان
تسعى الى زياده امداداتها الى الصين من
الغاز عن طريق هذا المشروع اولا وكما
تحدثت شركه غاسبروم اليوم ان حجم واردات
الغاز الروسي الى الصين قد وصلت الى 15
مليون ونصف متر مكعب في العام السابق وهي
في ازدياد حتى الان بالاضافه كما تحدث
ايضا الرئيس الروسي عن بناء روسيا لمحطه
محطه نوويه في كهربائيه في الصين يتم الان
العمل عليها كما قال الرئيس الروسي وهي
تمشي وجاريه وفقا لجدول الزمني الذي تم
وضعه للمشروع هذا في الصين شكرا لك كاتيا
طعمه مراسله العربيه حدثنا من موسكو
ورغم تقارب وجهات النظر والايديولوجيا لم
توقع موسكو وبكين على علاقه صداقه وشراكه
استراتيجيه قبل عام 2004 بعد حسم الخلافه
الحدودي الذي عمر لعقود والصين تخلت عن
اطماعها في الاراضي الروسيه لكن مناطق
نفوذ موسكو تبقى مباحه في ظل التسابق
العالمي نحو السمالتها
في الوقت الذي يغدق الزعيم الصيني على
روسيا بعبارات الصداقه والوفاء تناور بكين
بكل اوراقها داخل فناء روسيا الخلفي تطلق
بكين في الوقت نفسه مبادره خمسه زائد واحد
التي تستهدف دول اسيا الوسطى والتي وصفت
طويلا بانها حديقه موسكو الخلفيه لقاء
الرئيس الصيني بزعماء دول وسط اسيا تم
ترتيبه قبل مغادرته الى روسيا وهو ما
وصفته المعارضه الروسيه بخساره الحرب
الكبرى بجعل شريك اقتصادي يتحول الى عدو
غير معلن بعد ان تحولت مناطق النفوذ الى
ساحه تنافس مباحه الصين لن تواجه الوجود
الروسيه التاريخيه فقط بل ايضا لاعبين جدد
اهمهم تركيا التي اطلقت مشروع توحيد
العائله التركيه بما يجمعها من دين ولغه
شعارات شعبويه تقول الصين اضافه الى انها
لن تقف امام مشروعها البراغماتي الذي جاء
بمشاريع واستثمارات بمليارات الدولارات
وبالمقابل عين بكين على الطاقه
الكازاخستانيه واليد العامله الرخيصه في
تاجكستان وتركمانستان امام الوضع الجديد
اطلقت بروكسل مبادره اوروبيه وعلى لسان
ممثل خارجيتها
لاستماله دول وسط اسيا نحو المشروع
الاوروبي كبديل عن التدخل الروسي الذي
عرقل انشاء علاقات متعدده الاطراف مع هذه
الدول
[موسيقى]
اما موسكو فلا تجد الوقت مناسبا لفتح جبهه
جديده
الاولويات للحرب في اوكرانيا والانتصار في
نظر الكرملين كفيل بفرض واقع جيوسياسي
جديد
ومصير وقوف كييف في وجه موسكو سيكون اكبر
ضامن لولاء بقيه دول رابطه الدول المستقله
وعلى وقع زياره شيلي موسكو قال الامين
العام لحلف شمال الاطلسيان ستار بان روسيا
طلبت من الصين مساعده عسكريه لمساعدتها في
حرب اوكرانيا وان الصين تنظر في الامر
اي دليل على تقديم الصين مساعدات عسكريه
قاتله الى روسيا لكن رصدنا اشارات على طلب
روسيا ذلك وان الصين تنظر في الامر ورساله
ناهيه على الصين الا تقدم مساعدات عسكريه
قاتله لروسيا هذا سيكون دعم حرب غير شرعيه
ودعما للغاز غير القانوني لاوكرانيا وهو
امر لا يجب ان تفعله الصين
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن الترقب الامريكي لهذا
التقارب الصيني الروسي سينضم الينا من
واشنطن الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه دكتور كيف
تقرا اليوم الولايات المتحده توسيع نطاق
الطموح الصيني ومحاوله الصين وروسيا يعني
اذا صح التعبير اعاده صياغه مفاهيم جديده
لتطور العالم المعاصر
اولا بتقدير منذ عام او اكثر بقليل عندما
بدات الحرب انفجرت الحرب في اوكرانيا خرجت
بعض التحاليل من واشنطن الغرب تقول انه
الصين لها مصالح اقتصاديه خاصه بها وذاتيه
بها وبالتالي هي لن تقف مع روسيا وبالتالي
كان القرار بوضع هذه العقوبات الكبيره على
روسيا ظنا بان الصين لن تدخل في هذا
المعترك وهي تريد ان تكون محايده وقوه
اقتصاديه ما الذي حصل هذا الاجتماع هذه
القمه وقبل ذلك اتصالات كثيره بين الصين
وروسيا اثبتت هذه القمه ان الصين وروسيا
لهما علاقه استراتيجيه منذ قبل هذا العام
منذ عشرات الاعوام على الاقل منذ عشره
اعوام تقريبا وهم يقرران طرفان على اي
مستوى بامكانهم ان يظهران العالم ماذا
يجري روسيا حسب ما فهمنا من بعض التقارير
ليست بحاجه لنفس انواع السلاح التي يخشاها
الناتو او يخشاها واشنطن ما تحتاجه
من الصين هو توريد الغاز والنفط الى الصين
يعني السيوله وهذا الذي قلناه منذ عام
تقريبا والان الصين صعدت في في العلاقات
الاقتصاديه
بالعلم يعني ما يجري اليوم هو رساله فعلا
انه نحن لا نهابكم نقوم بمصلحتنا واذا
اردتم ان تدخلوا تدخلون
كفريق ينهي الحرب نحن مستعد دكتور التقارب
الاستراتيجي الذي تتحدث عنه على مستوى
الامن والطاقه والسياسه والاقتصاد اليوم
يعني الاعتماد ان كان بالبورصات او
بالتعامل بموسكو هو على العمله الصينيه
اكثر من اي شيء اخر بعد العزله التي فرضت
عليها اي من هذه المستويات هي الاخطر
اليوم بنظر واشنطن
بنظر واشنطن العميقه يعني الاجهزه
الاستخبارات والذين يعرفون بالضبط ماذا
يجري وليس ما يقال في الاعلام هو الوضع
الاقتصادي يعني كل العقيده الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه الغربيه لاضعاف روسيا لجعلها
تنسحب من اوكرانيا هو استضعافها في
الاقتصاد وليس في العسكر لانه الحلف
الناتو لا يريد مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا
لانها خطره نوويا اذا الصين اليوم وكانها
ترد على الغرب انا سافتح باب الاقتصاد مع
روسيا وهو ما يؤمن استمراريه
استمراريه موسكو بهذه الحرب دكتور هناك
نقطه اخرى ايضا منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وما
قبل كان هناك وجهتين نظر بالولايات
المتحده لا تعزل موسكو ولا تعزل الصين حتى
لا تتقاربا اكثر ويشكلان حلف وثيق ضد
الولايات المتحده اليوم وجهه النظر هذا
اثبتت
صوابيه يعني كيف ينظر اليها
انا كتبت شخصيا عن هذا الموضوع عده مقالات
يعني منتشره على تسعه اشهر ولكن عمليا لا
يمكن للولاد تحت الامريكيه واوروبا خاصه
اوروبا الغربيه الغنيه ان يعالجان موضوع
كل روسيا وكل الصين وربما حر الى حد ما
يعني طبعا للهند لانها الهند لم تقض لن
تاخذ موقف من هذا الموضوع بنفس الوقت هذا
مستحيل يعني قوه روسيا والصين اذا وضعت هي
قوه اسيويه هائله جدا كان يجب على هذه
الاداره ان تعالج موضوع اوكرانيا من دون
ان تعبئ الصين مع روسيا والعكس صحيح وهذه
وهذا ما يجري الان هو اثبات لهذه النظريه
هذه النظريه ايضا يتشعب منها موضوع
العقوبات فرض عقوبات على موسكو
دفع ذهبت اليوم الولايات المتحده الى مزيد
من العقوبات او على عقوبات جديده على
الصين ماذا يعني ذلك ايضا
يعني لا يمكنني ان اقول اكثر من ذلك وضعت
العقوبات على روسيا عقوبات قاسيه قويه جدا
جاءت الصين واعطت روسيا مجالا لكي تمر عبر
هذه العقوبات يعني ما يجري من مشاريع
اثنين نرى ما يجري في الشرق الاوسط يعني
كان هنالك محاوله لعزل ايران ايران فكت
هذه العزله عبر الصين
في العالم العربي
دكتور هذا التحالف مع ما يعنيه لاعاده رسم
خارطه التحالفات والنفوذ والقوى ان كان
بمنطقه شرق الاوسط وان كان بالعالم ايضا
ماذا يعني على السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
انا بتقديري عليها ان تتوقف ان تهدا ان
تدرس المرحله الجديده لانه الاستمرار
بالمرحله القديمه وترى واشنطن ما يجري
حاليا من نتائج على الارض ليس فقط في بقعه
واحده ولكن عندك بقع بما فيها فريق هي
وامريكا اللاتينيه عليها ان تتحاور مع
الكونغرس الاداره والكونجرس ويخرج
بسياسه جديده بتقدير وهذا ما اكتبه حاليا
شكرا لك دكتور وليد فارس الخبير في
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه حدثنا منه
واشنطن
اكثر من اربعين لقاء بين بوتين عززت
الصداقه بين الزعيمين على مر السنوات
عزيزي الرئيس صديقي العزيز اهلا بك في
روسيا في موسكو
كانت زياره تشيل الاولى لموسكو
اعتقد اننا متشابهان في الشخصيه
الصين وروسيا شريكان وحليفان طبيعيان
الصين دعمت روسيا بعد ضمها للقرن
توقيع اتفاقيات اسلحه وعدم اعتداء بين
البلدين
الاعلان عن شراكه استراتيجيه شامله بين
توقيع شراكه غير محدوده بين الصين وروسيا
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الكونغرس يدرس تجريد البيت الابيض من
سلطات بدء الحد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مقابل الزياره الصينيه
والتوافق مع روسيا الغرب لم يترك ياف
وحيده تراقب لقاءات الزعيمين في موسكو
فبعثوا برساله طمانه بانه ليس وحيدا
الرساله حملتها زياره رئيس الوزراء
الياباني كيشيدا الذي تشهد بلاده علاقات
متوتره مع الصين في الاونه الاخيره كشي
الذي وصل الى اكياس زياره مفاجئه سيلتقي
زيلينسكي ليؤكد من جديد دعم بلاده
لاوكرانيا في حربها ضد الغزو الروسي
[موسيقى]
ميدانيا شحنه من صواريخ كروز الروسيه من
طراز كاليبر لم تصل الى وجهتها بل بغتها
انفجار ضخم خلال عمليه النقل وتدمرت تماما
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ودون تبني الحادث
اعلنت ان الشحنه استهدفت اثناء نقلها عبر
سكك الحديديه في منطقه جنكوي شمال شبه
جزيره القرم التي تعد موطنا لاحد اهم
المطارات العسكريه الروسيه هناك وتلعب
دورا مهما كخطئ امداد صواريخ كاليبر او ما
تعرف بواحده من اهم الاسلحه في القصف
البري للبحريه الروسيه دخلت في الخدمه عام
1994 تم تصميم نموذجين من هذا الصاروخ
الذي يحلق بسرعه تقل عن سرعه الصوت احدها
مضاد للسفن والاخر مضاد للغواصات مع
القدره طبعا على حمل رؤوس نوويه يبلغ طول
الصاروخ نحو سته امتار ومدى عمل هي يتراوح
قادر على التحليق على ارتفاعات منخفضه
للغايه وقد يحمل متفجرات تزن نحو 450 كيلو
جراما تقريبا منظومه الملاحه الفضائيه
الناشطه التي تعتمدها صواريخ كاليبر
تساعدها على المناوره فتلك الصواريخ لا
تتحرك الى الهدف في خط مستقيم كما نشاهد
هنا كما يمكن اطلاقها من انابيب عموديه
مثبته ومثبته على سفن صغيره يصل طولها الى
200 قدم مثل الطرادات على عكس توماهوك
الامريكي الذي ينتمي لنفس العائله من
صواريخ كروز ويتطلب اطلاقه سفنا يبلغ
طولها 500 قدم على الاقل في وقت مشاهدينا
تفاخرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان صواريخ
كاليبر لن تنفذ تشكك استونيا واوكرانيا
وغيرها من الدول في
[موسيقى]
هل سيتم اعتقال ترامب وماذا سيحدث اذا تم
توقيف ترامب اليوم البدايه كانت من الرئيس
الامريكي السابق نفسه حين قال عبر منصته
يتروس سوشيال ميديا انه يتوقع توقيفه
اليوم الثلاثاء في قضيه دسيد مبلغ من
المال في عام 2016
لممثله اباحيه يعتقد انه كان على علاقه
بها المدعي العام في منهات ابلغ وهو
ديمقراطي طبعا اتهم باستهداف ترامب لتحقيق
مكاسب سياسيه وقد يستخدم الرئيس السابق
هذا الادعاء اساسا في دفاعه عن نفسه ضد
التهم الموجهه اليه ويمكنه ايضا الطعم
فيما اذا كانت فتره التقادم الفتره التي
يحق فيها للشخص تقديم دعوه قضائيه جراء
الضرر الذي حصل له قد انتهت من الناحيه
السياسيه مشاهدينا من غير الواضح كيف يمكن
لاي لائحه اتهام ان تؤثر على فرص ترامب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2024 لكنه سيكون
اول رئيس امريكي سابق يواجه محاكمه جنائيه
واذا تم ترشيحه للانتخابات بالفعل قد
يحاكم ترامب اثناء حملته الانتخابيه في
عام 2024 وهو حدث غير مسبوق طبعا واذا تم
انتخابه رئيسا للولايات المتحده مره اخرى
فلن تكون لديه القدره على العفو عن نفسه
من التهم الجنائيه المنسوبه اليها
[موسيقى]
كيف ستسير اجراءات توقيف ترامب هذا السؤال
يقول بانه تتطلب اي لائحه اتهام من ترامب
السفر من فلوريدا حيث يعيش الى مكتب
المدعي العام في نيويورك وطبعا هناك
للاستسلام ونظرا لكون قضيه راب من ضمن
قضايا اصحاب الياقات البيضاء وهي تلك التي
تتعلق بالجرائم غير العنيفه المرتكبه من
قبل رجال الاعمال واصحاب النفوذ فقد يذهب
ترامب طوعا الى السلطات حيث سيتم تصويره
واخذ بصمات اصابعه قبل مثوله امام المحكمه
وعلى اي حال قدر الخبراء القانونيون بان
اي محاكمه للرئيس الامريكي الصادق ترامب
ستكون باكثر من عام او بعد اكثر من عام
واذا حدث ذلك فقد تتزامن المحاكمه مع
الاشهر الاخيره من انتخابات عام
2024 التي يسعى فيها ترامب للعوده والعوده
مثيره الجدل الى البيت الابيض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ايام ايام
[تصفيق]
معركه سياسيه والصفات بين اعضاء الحزبين
فحتى غريم ترامب الجمهوري حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا
عن صمته منتقدا المدعي العام في من هاتم
بنيويورك ورغم المرشح الجمهوريه المحتمل
للرئاسه تعهد بان مكتبه لن يتدخل في تسليم
ترامب الى نيويورك الا انه لم يقدم الدعم
للتراب وبدلا من ذلك بدا انه يسخر من
الموقف الذي وضع ترامبت نفسه فيه خاصه انه
يحاول العوده للحياه السياسيه من خلال
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه حاكم فلوريدا
قال في مؤتمر صحفي اقيم في الولايه انه لا
يعرف ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث في قضيه دفع
الاموال لشراء صمت ممثله واضاف انه يفضل
عدم الحديث عن ذلك مشيرا الى انه لديه
قضايا وصفها بالحقيقيه للتعامل معها في
فلوريدا بدلا من ذلك
[موسيقى]
شاطر
ات وضعت شرطي حواجز حديديه حول محكمه
منهاتن وذلك تحسبا للاحتجاجات التي من
الممكن ان تندلع بعد مداعى الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انصاره
للخروج والاحتجاج في حال قبض عليه وتاتي
هذه الاستبعاد الاستعدادات في الوقت الذي
توجه فيها اتهامات لترامب في نيويورك بسبب
مزاعم عن دفعه مبلغا ماليا لاسكات نجمه
افلام اباحيه خلال حملته الانتخابيه عام
المزيد من نيويورك مع الزميل حسين الطود
مراسل العربيه حسين يعني كيف هي الاجواء
من هناك ويعني كنا سالنا زميلنا ناديه عن
احتماليه توقيف ترامب قالت لا شيء محسوم
حتى الساعه هل تغير شيء
حتى الان بالفعل ليال لا شيء محسوم انا
الان امام محكمه الجنايات في منهات جنوب
نيويورك هذه المحكمه التي تظهر خلفيه وحيث
توجد هيئه المحلفين الكبرى التي ما زالت
لم تنتهي من الاستماع للشهود بعد ذلك
ستقرر سترسل الملف الى المدعي العام
البنبراج الذي هو من يقرر ان كان سيوجه
الاتهامات ولكن حتى اللحظه لا يوجد اي خبر
حول حول ذلك من كان سيوجه الاتهامات اليوم
او غدا او الاسبوع المقبل او ان كان سيوجه
الاتهامات اصلا بطبيعه الحلقه الاجواء هنا
مليئه يعني هناك وجود امني مكثف هناك ايضا
وجود لوسائل اعلام متعدده منتشره في هذا
المكان في هذه الساحه كان هناك في الصباح
كان هناك صحيفه في نيويورك تحدثت عن وجود
قنابل في هذا المكان ولكن شرطه نيويورك
اكدت ان هذا هذا البلاغ كان كاذبا ولا
توجد
اي قنبله في هذه المنطقه لكن طبعا كما
قلنا هناك اجراءات امنيه مشدده اتخذتها
السلطات السلطات الفا القانون هنا
بالتنسيق مع الخدمات السريه من اجل ضبط
واحتواء اي اعمال عنف
توجيه التهم هل رصدتم يعني
تجمع او وجود لاي من انصار ترامب بمحيط
المحكمه او بالمنطقه هناك
بالفعل ليال هناك تجمعات لان صارت ترامب
ولمعارضيه ترامب هنا الان طبعا العدد بدا
يخف الان عن كان عليه عندما اتينا هنا
تقريبا على الساعه الثانيه عشر ونصف ولكن
هناك عدد كان من مؤيدين ترامب ومن معارضيه
تظاهرات اللافتات كانت واضحه كما قلنا
يوجد له مناصرون ويوجد له ايضا معارضون
ولكن شرطه نيويورك قالت بانها تراقب كل
هذه التحركات وايضا تراقب وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وتحديدا تويتر لمعرفه ماذا كان
هناك دعوات لتنظيم احتجاجات قد تتحول الى
احتياجات عنيفه ولكن حتى الان تقول بان
الامور تسير على ما يرام ولا يوجد اي مؤشر
على ذلك احسنت باختصار لو سمحت بالمسار
القانوني الان والدستوري ما الذي سيحصل
بالساعات المقبله
اذا تم توجيه الاتهام فهو حسب ما قال احد
محاميه فهو سيسلم نفسه للمدعي العام اما
ان ياتي الى هنا الى منهات الى هذه هذا
المبنى حيث توجد المحكمه محكمه الجنايات
ويتم اخذ صوره له واخذ بصمات ولكن من غير
مستبعد ان يتم تكبير يديه كما قيل احتراما
لمنصبها السابق رئيس الدوله
عادي ولكن القانون سيطبق عليه مع عدا هذا
الاستثناء طبعا الاجراءات حتى الان
الليالي غير واضحه بسبب ان هذه هذه القضيه
هي السابقه في التاريخ الامريكي لم يحدث
سابقا وجهت اتهامات لرئيس السابق لذلك من
غير الواضح بحسب جميع وسائل الامريكيه ما
هي هذه الاجراءات بالتحديد ولكن يتوقعون
بان لا يتم تكبيله بان لا يتم عرضه على
الجمهور سيكون ذلك احتراما لمنصب الرئيس
ولهذه المؤسسه كما قال حتى محاميه السابق
بانه يتمنى بان يحدث لذلك احتراما لمنصب
الرئاسه ولكن ايضا هناك معلومه بانه يمكنه
ان يسلم نفسه للسلطات وليس بالضروره ان
يسافر الى من هاته لكي يسلم نفسه هنا يمكن
ان يسلم نفسه للسلطه اذا اراد ذلك ومحاموه
يقولون بان ترامب اذا وجهت له لائحه
الاتهام هو لن يقاوم لن يكون هناك مواجهه
بين حمايته كرئيس وبين السلطات التي
ستستسلمه انما سيقبل بتقديم نفسه بتسليم
نفسي للسلطات لكي تاخذ الامور مجراها شكرا
لك حسين طرد مراسل العربيه حدثنا من
نيويورك
[موسيقى]
قبل 20 عاما صوت مجلسا نواب والشيوخ
الامريكيين
لمنح الرئيس جورج بوش سلطه غزو العراق غير
ان الكونجرس يدرس حاليا تجريد البيت
الابيض من سلطات بدء الحرب وفق صحيفه ذا
تايمز البريطانيه حيث يستعد اعضاء
الكونجرس للتصويت على الغاء التفويض
باستخدام القوه العسكريه الذي تم تمديده
الى ما بعد هدفه الاصلي وفق تعبير مؤيدي
الخطوه ومن المتوقع ان يتم تمرير مشروع
القانون من الحزبين في مجلس الشيوخ في
الايام المقبله
[موسيقى]
الامريكي وسلطه اعلان الحرب من المقرر ان
يصوت مجلس الشيوخ على الغاء سلطه منحت عام
2002 للرئيس الاسبق جورج دبليو بوش
ايضا يسعى المشروع لالغاء تفويض اخر اجاز
حرب الخليج عام
1991 الرئيس جو بايدن يدعم جهود الغاء
التفويضين
مؤيد القرار يرون انه تجاوز اهدافه وان
على الكونجرس استعاده بعض السلطه من البيت
الابيض
مشروع القرار اجتاز تصويتا اوليا يوم
الخميس في مجلس الشيوخ بتاييد كل اعضائه
الديمقراطيين ودعم 19 جمهوريا
مصير المشروع في مجلس النواب الذي يقوده
الحزب الجمهوري غير مؤكد
بموجب الدستور الاميركي الرئيس هو القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه لكن للكونجرس حصرا
سلطه اعلان الحرب
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى الملف الاوكراني
الروسي
سننتقل الى مؤتمر صحافه على ما يبدو ان
المؤتمر يعني انتهى هو مؤتمر صحافه عقد
بين كل من وزير رئيس الوزراء الياباني
والرئيس الاوكراني فولو وهي زياره طبعا
التي قمنا بانها تتزامن مع الزياره
الصينيه الى موسكو بالعوده الى التاسعه
دانه السعوديه تصريحات المسيئه والعنصريه
الصادره عن احد المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
بحق فلسطين وشعبها وفقا لبيان صادر عن
وزاره الخارجيه الخارجيه السعوديه اكدت
موقف الرياض الرافض لتلك التصريحات كونها
تنشر خطاب الكراهيه تحرض على العنف وتقوض
محادثات السلام واكدت المملكه على دعمها
للجهود الدوليه بهدف حل القضيه الفلسطينيه
على اساس مبادره السلام العربي
من جهته وصف وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن
الصفدي تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
وسلوكي بان تصريحات تحريضيه وعنصريه وتعكس
فكرا اقصائيا متطرفا
كما قلنا التصريحات العنصريه التحريضيه
الاستفزازيه التي اطلقها وزير في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
واطلاق هذه التصريحات على منبر يحمل خريطه
مزعومه لاسرائيل تضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله وتضم المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
هذه تصريحات ومواقف وتصرفات تحريضيه
عنصريه
تعكس فكرا اخصائيا
عنصريه متطرفا اكدنا ادانته واستنكاره
ورفضه وتواصلنا مع المجتمع الدولي
لابراز خطوره مثل هذا الفكر الاقصائي
العنصريه التحريضي وانعكاساته
على ليس فقط العمليه السلميه ولكن ما
يرسله من رساله حول خطوره هذا الفكر
العنصري المتطرف
مشاهدينا بموازات هذه التصريحات هناك ايضا
تصريح الان للخارجيه الامريكيه تصف فيه
تصريحات وزير ماليه اسرائيل بشان
الفلسطينيين بالخطيره وايضا الخارجيه
الامريكيات تبدين انزعاجها الشديد من
الغاء الكنيسه اعاده المستوطنات لشمال
الضفه اذا والخارجيه الامريكيه تقول بان
تشريع الكنيسه لبعض المستوطنات استفزازيه
وتنتهك الوعود اذا كانت هذه اخر العواجل
بالموضوع بموضوع التصعيد الاسرائيلي
الاخير ضد الفلسطينيين الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ايضا وصفت تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه اليمينيه المتطرف التي انكر
فيها وجود الشعب الفلسطيني بانها غير
مسؤوله دعايه الاشخاص الذين تم استدعائهم
الى مناصب عليا داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لاظهار الكرامه المطلوبه واحترام كرامه
الاخرين والامتناع عن اي عمل او اعلان
يمكن ان يساهم في تصعيد التوترات في
المنطقه
في الاثناء مشاهدينا صادق الكنيسه
الاسرائيليه على قانون اقره عام 2005
ويمنح للاسرائيليين حق العوده الى
مستوطنات سابقه تم اخلائها في شمال الضفه
الغربيه في وقت في ذات السياق ذكر موقع
اسرائيليه ان الغاء القانون الساري منذ
ثمانيه عشر عاما والذي سمح بالانسحاب
بالقطاع غزه ومن اربع مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه سيتيح للمستوطنين الاقامه في
مستوطنات بالضفه قرب نابلس
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
ايطاليا تفتح تحقيقا في انتهاك تيك توك
قواعد النشر والنرويج تنصح موظفيها بعدم
تحميل التطبيق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت هيئه مكافحه
الاحتكار الايطاليه ان تحقيق مع وحده تيك
توك الايرلنديه يشمل المسؤوله عن علاقات
العملاء الاوروبيين بالاضافه الى القسمين
البريطاني واوضحت الهيئه انه لا توجد
انظمه كافيه للاشراف على المحتوى المنشور
من قبل اطراف ثالثه كما ينتهك التطبيق
الارشادات التي تنص على ازاله المحتوى
الخطير والذي يحرض على الانتحار واذيه
النفس وسوء التغذيه ومن جانبه رفض متحدث
باسم تيك توك هذه المزاعم قائلا ان الشركه
لا تسمح بالمحتوى الذي يعرض او يروج او
يعرض او يروج لانشطه وتحديات خطيره مؤكدا
بان الشركه ستتعاون مع التحقيق بشكل كامل
اما وزيره العدل النرويجيه فنصحت الموظفين
الرسميين في البلاد بعدم تحميل تطبيق تيك
توك الصيني وتطبيق تيليجرام الروسيه على
اجهزتهم الخاصه بالعمل وقالت الوزيره
النرويجيه بان اجهزه الاستخبارات حددت
روسيا والصين على انهما عمل الخطر
الرئيسيان للمصالح الامنيه النرويجيه
مشيره الى ان الشبكتين يتم استخدامهما
لتاثير على النرويجيين من خلال المعلومات
المضلله والاخبار الكاذبه
وفي الولايات المتحده خلصت تقرير لشركه
الامن السيبرانيه ان اكثر من 20 موقعا
حكوميا يحتوي على شفره تتبع الويب والتي
اعدتها باي دانس الشركه الام لتيك توك
وفقا
شركه الامن السيبراني قامت بمراجعه اكثر
من
3500 شركه وكيان حكومي لتجد
بكسلات التتبع الخاصه بتيك توك في سبعه
وعشرين ولايه امريكيه وجد وجود طبعا الرمز
يعني ضررا بالامن القومي الامريكي وفق
مسؤوليه اداره بايدن المتحدثه باسم تيك
توك قالت في بيان لها ان تيك توك كحال
منصات الاخرى يستخدم البيانات لتحسين
الخدمات الاعلانيه
[موسيقى]
رشاقه امازون تستوجب اقاله الاف الموظفين
الاخرين في مواجهه المخاوف الاقتصاديه
المتزايده القول هنا لصحيفه التي اكدت بان
الشركه ستقيل تسعه الاف موظف خلال
الاسابيع المقبله بهدف طبعا جعل الشركه
اكثر رشاقه واضافت ان عمليات تسريح جديده
ستؤثر بشكل كبير على الموظفين في فراق
الحوسبه والاعلان وفريق توفير حلول
التكنولوجيا بالاضافه طبعا الى منصه تويتش
للبث المباشر الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
امازون اوضح بان الاقتصاد غير المؤكد وعدم
اليقين دفعهم الى تقليل التكاليف وعدد
الموظفين ولفت الى ان التخطيط السنوي
لشركه امازون كان مدفوعا بالرغبه في ان
تكون اصغر حجما وان اتخاذ هذه القرارات
سيتم بين منتصف واواخر ابريل المقبل هذا
وكانت امازون اعلنت في يناير انها ستتخلى
عن اكثر من 18000 موظف من قوتها لما له من
فوائد طبعا على الشركه على المدى الطويل
وفق تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا حيث التملم والاستياء في الشارع
لا يزال متواصلا لينذر بالمزيد من الهزات
السياسيه والاضطرابات الاجتماعيه بعد
تمرير اصلاح نظام التقاعد
قنبله موقوته قد تنفجر في اي لحظه لتدمر
معها مؤسسات الجمهوريه الخامسه في فرنسا
ان توصلت الاحتجاجات الرافضه لتمرير اصلاح
نظام التقاعد المعارضه اكدت استمرارها في
اتباع كل الطرق لاسقاط قانون التقاعد ومعه
الحكومه بعد ان اخفق نوابها في الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه في حجم الثقه عن حكومه
اليزابيث حيث اعلن رئيس الجمعيه الوطنيه
يا البراون بفيت عن فشلها
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للتصويت بحجم الثقه هي
287 بما انه لم يتم الوصول الى الاغلبيه
المطلوبه فلم يتم اعتماد اقتراح سحب الثقه
اما المحاميه ماتيلد بانو من حزب فرنسا
الابيه فوصفت الحكومه بالميته احتجنا فقط
الى تسعه اصوات لحجب وكسر هذه الحكومه
واصلاحها الحكومه ميته بالفعل في اعين
الشعب الفرنسي ولم تعد تتمتع بالشرعيه
اتهامات بالبؤس المعنوي والسياسي وعدم
امتلاك الشرعيه الشعبيه ولا النيابيه
يواجهها الرئيس الفرنسي الذي بات مستقبله
على المحاك اتهامات قد تدخل البلاد في
ازمه حكم هي الاولى في تاريخ فرنسا
مارلو فان زعيمه اقصى اليسار كان لها راي
اخر حيث اتهمت الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
بالفشل الذريع وبان سياسته ستساهم في
تمزيق الدوله الفرنسيه
صحيفه لوبينيون محسوبه على الليبراليين في
فرنسا اكدتنا الازمه قد تتفاقم والحكومه
ستتعرض لخسائر كبيره وهي تخوض معركه اصلاح
نظام التقاعد اما صحيفه لمن التل محسوبه
على اقصى اليسار فاشارت الى وضع لا يحتمل
وح اله من الانهيار في قواعد الحكومه
الفرنسيه
مراقبون للتطورات الحاصله اكدوا ان
استعمال منطق القوه في تمرير قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد سيؤدي لاغراق البلاد في
المزيد من الفوضى
المزيد حول التطورات في الشارع الفرنسي
ينضم الينا من باريس فادي الدهوك مراسل
العربيه يعني التجمعات ما زالت مستمره كيف
هي الصوره من هناك وماذا يعمل يعني
المتظاهرين
اهلا ليال نعم التجمعات ما زالت مستمره
تخرج في كل المدن الفرنسيه حقيقه وكلها
غير مرخصه هؤلاء يخرجون من دون طلب ترخيص
من الشرطه التي تحاول تفريغ كل هذه
التجمعات وعاده ما تبدا الاشتباكات ليلا
هنا كما ترون في ساحه الجمهوريه عدد كبير
جدا من المتظاهرين تمكنوا من التجمع في
هذه الساحه بعدما اطلقوا نداءات او دعوات
للتظاهر في ثلاث نقاط في باريس لتضليل
الشرطه نحن كنا في في موقع اخر لهذه
التظاهرات المفترضه لكن لم تكن هنا وهي
الان تخرج في ساحه الجمهوريه طبعا هناك
حشد امني كثيف جدا يرافق هذه التظاهرات
ويحاول ان يفرقها الشرطه تتدخل بعنف حقيقه
وهناك حملات اعتقالات كبيره جدا تحدث وزير
الداخليه اليوم جيرالدرمانا قام بالاعلان
عن 855 معتقلا منذ يوم الخميس الماضي وهذه
الاعداد هي ضخمه جدا في فرنسا لحمل اعتقال
تشنها الشرطه وبعضها كان بشكل عشوائي
ادانتها
انترناشونال وايضا هناك عدد كبير من
النواب والمسؤولين المنتخبين وحتى القضاه
بداوا يعربون عن قلقهم من تصرفات الشرطه
لانها بدات ايضا تستخدم تكتيكات لاصطياد
المتظاهرين حيث تنصب لهم كمائن وهذه
الاساليب ممنوعه في فرنسا محظوره لكي
تستخدمها الشرطه
يعني بالجانب الاخر النقابات اليمين ما
يعني ما الخطه الذي سيعملون عليها للايام
والاسابيع المقبله وهل ياملون باحداث اي
تغيير
النقابات تحضر لليوم الكبير للتظاهرات
والاضراب في الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر
يوم الخميس المقبل اي بعد يومين هذه
التظاهرات هي بدعوه من نقبات العمال وايضا
الاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه الاحزاب الخمسه
التي تعارض سياسات الرئيس كلها تدعم هذه
التظاهرات هم يعولون على حجم الغضب في
الشارع وايضا على الاضرابات وما يمكن ان
تقوم بتغيير هذا الوضع لان حتى الان
المتظاهرين الذين يخرجونهم كلهم من شريحه
الشبان والطلاب يخرجون من الجامعات وبشكل
العشوائي وغير منسق وسلطات تجد صعوبه
كبيره في التعامل معهم لانه لا يوجد بينهم
قائد للتحاور او التفاوض معهم وهم بداوا
يعطونا زخما جديدا وكبيرا جدا للتظاهرات
لانهم يقومون بهذه التظاهرات في كل
الشوارع خصوصا في العاصمه ويقومون بعمليه
احراق في الشوارع فادي يعني هذه التظاهرات
والتجمعات والاصرار على البقاء في الشارع
يضر طبعا بقطاعات عده وبالاقتصاد الفرنسي
ما ابرز القطاعات المتضرره اليوم من كل ما
يحصل
النقابات تعمل في ان يقوم هذا الاضراب
وهذه الاحتجاجات بشل الاقتصاد الفرنسي
بهدف الضغط على الحكومه وعلى الرئيس لسحب
هذا القانون قانون رفع سن التقاعد الى 64
عاما هم يعتبرون ان هذه هي الخطوه الامثل
للضغط على الحكومه حتى ان قوه كثيره من
اليسار وخصوصا حزب فرنسا غير الخاضعه التي
الذي يتزعمه كان قد دعا الى اسقاط الحكومه
عبر عبر الاحتجاجات
وخصوصا عندما فشل تصويت البرلمان في حجم
الثقه منها هو قال يجب الان او الكلمه
الان للشارع لسحب الثقه من الحكومه في
الشارع ياملون في ان يؤثر ذلك على
الاقتصاد من خلال الاضرابات التي بدات تعم
قطاعات كبيره اليوم
اليوم هناك موقع
لمستودعات النفط او احدى المصافي الكبيره
في فرنسا احد اكبر المصافي في فرنسا توقفت
عن العمل بسبب الاضراب وهناك مصافه اخرى
سوف تنضم الى هذا على كل حال فادي يعني
سنبقى نتابع معكم مع الزملاء كل تطورات
الشارع الفرنسي شكرا لك فادي الدهوك مراسل
العربيه حدثنا من باريس
بنك الاحتياط الفيدرالي كان اول من توجه
له اصابع او توجه له اصابع الاتهام في
سقوط البنوك الامريكيه ثلاثه بسبب ضعف
واضح في الرقابه على هذه البنوك ويضاف الى
ذلك البطء في اتخاذ قرارات لانقاذ الوضع
المزيد في تقرير للزملاء في قسم الاقتصاد
ما ان تم الاعلان عن انهيار ثلاثه بنوك
امريكيه في اسبوع واحد وتشكيلها لاول ازمه
ماليه بهذا الحجم منذ العام 2008 بدات
اصابع الاتهام تتجه نحو من قد يكون
المتسبب بهذه الازمه بعض الخبراء رمي
المسؤوليه على الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي وقراراته المتاخره بمعالجه
الازمات فبعد اتهامات للاحتياطي الفيدرالي
بانه تاخر كثيرا في تدارك ازمه ارتفاع
التضخم بعدم رفعه لاسعار الفائده بوتيره
سريعه اظهرت ازمه البنوك المنهاره ثغره
كبيره في مهام الفيدرالي واهمها الرقابه
على البنوك
فقبل اكثر من عام من سقوط بنك اس في بي
عين الاحتياطي الفيدرالي فيسكو فريقا
لمعينه اصول البنك واطلق الفريق المتخصص
انذارات عده ومطالب باصلاحات هامه في بنك
وبنهايه العام الماضي طالب الفريق
باصلاحات شامله لمواجهه مخاطره ارتفاع
الفائده واثرها على ميزانيه البنك من جهه
اخرى جاءت تنظيمات القطاع المالي في عهد
الرئيس السابق ترامب والتي خففت قيود
الافصاح على البنوك التي تتجاوز اصولها
250 مليار دولار عاملا اخر في ازمه سقوط
البنوك الثلاثه خاصه بعد اعفائها من بعض
القيود على راس المال المتوفر لديها
واستثنائها من اختبارات فحص جهد المالي
وفي تطور لافت وفي اواخر العام 2021
تعيين نائب رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في
سان فرانسيسكو جريجوري والمسؤول عن رقابه
بنك اس بي بي انذاك لاستلام مهمه اخرى تم
مثلت بان يكون المسؤول عن الجهه التنظيميه
في بنك سيلفر غيت الذي تعثر هذا الشهر
ايضا بيكر الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك قام قبل
اسبوعين من سقوط البنك ببيع اسهم في البنك
بثلاثه ملايين
دولار وهو يخضع حاليا لتحقيق من وزاره
العدل لقيامه بذلك
تمسك البنكي بسندات قديمه ذات عائد منخفض
جدا لوقت الاستحقاق مقابل فوائد اكبر
يدفعها على ودائع العملاء كان كفيلا بسقوط
مدون اشعله اندفاع العملاء لسحب ودائعهم
من البنك
شادي الزعيم العربيه
[موسيقى]
كسل وقل الطاشات نتجت عن سنتين قضاها طلاب
وموظفون يدرسون ويعملون عن بعض خلال جائحه
كورونا دراسه جديده خلصت الى ان العالم
اصبح اقل نشاطا منذ الوباء وان الاكثر
تاثرا هي فئه الشباب اي الذين تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 18 عاما وثلاثين عاما واضافت
بان النشاط البدني انخفض خلال الجائحه دون
ان يعود لمستواها الطبيعي بعدها وافق هذه
الدراسه يخطو الناس حوالي 600 خطوه يوميا
اقل من ما كان عليه قبل بدء الوباء في
الولايات المتحده مثلا الدراسه شملت ايضا
5500 شخص في الولايات المتحده وارتدى
المشاركون فيها اجهزه تتبع للنشاط اليومي
لعشر ساعات على الاقل يوميا هذا هو حذرت
الدراسه من ان استمرار الوضع على حاله قد
يزيد من مخاطر الاصابه بامراض القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه والسمنه وارتفاع ضغط
الدم والسكري وغيرها من الحالات المرتبطه
بقله الحركه
[موسيقى]
بدا العام الدراسي الجديد في افغانستان
بدون الفتيات بعدما علقت طلبان تعليم
الفتيات في الجامعات وفي المدارس حكومه
طالبان كانت وعدت عند عودتها الى السلطه
باحترام حقوق المراه لكن جاء قرار منع
الطالبات ليجرد النساء للمره الثانيه من
كافه الحريات والحقوق الضئيله التي كنا قد
حصلنا عليها المزيد من التفاصيل في هذا
التقرير لعبد الله نادر
هما تلميذه في مدرسه حكوميه في العاصمه
كابول كانت تنتظر ان تفتح المدرسه ابوابها
اليوم امامها وامام زميلاتها الا انها
تيقنت ان انتظارها وانتظار زميلاتها قد
يطول
العام الدراسي دون الفتيات بعد شتاء قارص
ووصول فصل الربيع ملايين من براعم مستقبل
افغانستان كانت قرارات طالبان منعت عنها
ذلك لتحبس الفتيات خلف جدران المنازل عبد
الانادر العربيه كابول
اعلنت المحكمه العليا في السعوديه ان
الخميس هو اول ايام عيد اول ايام رمضان
المبارك
وايضا ذلك بعد تعذر رؤيه هلال شهر رمضان
في مرصدين بعدما ايضا دعت المحكمه العليا
في السعوديه بوقت سابق الى تحري رؤيه هلال
شهر رمضان اليوم وبهذا الاعلان يكون يوم
غد الاربعاء هو المتمم لشهر شعبان على ان
يكون الخميس هو اول ايام شهر رمضان لهذا
العام
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
حقبه جديده في العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه
تتوج باتفاقيات شراكه شامله وتعاون
استراتيجي
ومن كياف رئيس الوزراء الياباني يشد الدعم
بلاده لاوكرانيا في مواجهه الغزو الروسي
اجراءات امنيه مشدده في نيويورك تحسبا
لاعمال الشغب من اصاله ترامب حال اعتقاله
اليوم
مزيد من التضييق على تيك توك في اوروبا
وواشنطن تكشف عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات
المواقع الحكوميه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العدديه
مستمره والان الى 360 والزميلارين بوجمره
ريم مساء الخير مع الوان الربيع الزاهيه
يا ريم ماذا لديك دائما نحاول ان نصفي بعض
الالوان اليوم لدينا زياره رئيس الصيني
الى روسيا لدينا كذلك ترامب بين مذكره
الاعتقال بين التحقيق كيف سيكون موضوع
وتيك توك ملاحق في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وايطاليا والمزيد من الملفات الاخرى
تفضل شكرا لك